- [Girl] You gotta be quicker than that.
- Ah (bleep)! (laughs)
Ok, I'm done!
I can't. I'm wounded.
That's definitely not safe for children.
- I think I had some,
like, workout Barbies,
but I don't really know if those
were 90's or not.
- Tetris?
Is that 90's?
- It was jingle with it,
that was like
(humming)
- Socker Boppers!
- It's more fun than a pillow fight!
You know?
- I have no idea!
- Nothing's better than
encouraging kids to be violent.
What could possibly go wrong?
- Suit up!
- Whoa!
- I like it!
I would play with it.
- I feel bad.
She's about to win.
- The good thing about this is
if you're playing by a lake,
maybe on vacation,
you fall in--
- Oh yeah!
You can use it as a floating device.
(laughing)
- This is the first time
I've thrown a punch at a girl.
- I feel like this is a good
stress reliever.
- I guess you learn self defense
from an early age.
- Goo Green Gak.
- It smells like...
a condom?
- Ew.
What are you supposed to do with this?
- It makes, like, fart sounds.
- I used to imagine myself
being slimed.
Like, I'd turn on the shower head
and be like, "Whoa!"
Yeah.
- I feel like it would be kinda weird
to play with this for hours on end.
- It's not like Play-Doh,
you can't shape it,
and it can't copy things.
It's for a disgusting sound.
Being juvenile.
I love it.
- Oh wow!
Oh, I know exactly what this is!
- It's harder than it looks.
- You gotta move over.
I remember this, wait.
- I'm gonna hit my foot.
(laughing)
- I feel like I'm wearing
one of those things
that people in jail wear.
(laughing)
- Again, it's a workout!
I would play this for hours
and then sleep it off.
- Yeah, I hate it.
- I think this is so fun.
I'm excited.
- I wonder how many children like me
would crack their face open.
It's not safe.
- Again with the bright colors.
- This velcro is like really nice.
- Makes me feel like
I can actually play ball.
- If this game was created now,
you'd be able to throw
it from this as well.
You'd press a button,
and the material would change.
- Yeah, there's a button
that will release.
Or the ball is like a hologram.
- This one's actually the most fun so far.
- Ha!
- I feel so athletic.
This looks not safe at all.
- Is this illegal?
I feel like there could be
a lot of broken ankles.
- I feel really tall.
- This is like adult assembly required.
- Oh my gosh!
- It's fun!
- It's like a portable trampoline!
- Just walking around.
Cause I'm on the moon.
- Look how makeshift these look.
These just look like a buckets
with rubber bands.
- I can make music videos
in moon shoes.
- This actually a lot of fun.
- It's kinda fun to just stand like this.
- Woo!
- Well, the moon shoes
were pretty fun.
Even though I don't understand them.
- I think these toys are pretty awesome.
Nowadays, kids are always
with their tablets
and their iPhones.
This is something that you don't see
kids playing with nowadays.
- Everything was so much more complicated.
- It teaches you about staying active
and being healthy.
So I think they're perfect for children.
- Nineties toys are pretty awesome.